I want to tell you something you might
not like
your small potatoes as far as the
universe is concerned now
go take that personally I mean I am too
everyone is
and I'm not just talking about Carl
Sagan's billions and billions thing
where he tells us of the billions of
galaxies each containing billions of
stars and you're just a speck on a tiny
planet orbiting one of them
now I'm talking about something even
more humbling
well those claims of us being merely a
dust mode Among the Stars is true
there's an even grander measure of our
insignificance
you of course are made of matter which
means atoms stars and galaxies are also
made of atoms which might make us feel a
bit better about ourselves however
matter made of atoms is only a small
fraction of the matter and energy of the
universe
atoms make up only about five percent of
the cosmos
the remainder is made of two substances
that we've only indirectly detected
called Dark Matter and dark energy
I'm going to talk about both of them and
their effect on the history and
evolution of the universe over the next
few lessons it's going to be pretty
mind-blowing to be honest
however in this lesson I want to focus
exclusively on one of them specifically
dark matter
I want to tell you what researchers
think dark matter is and why we believe
that it exists
I should warn you that the data we have
so far is strong but still a bit
circumstantial which means that we are
not absolutely 100 sure that dark matter
is a real thing
we're pretty sure and I'll also give you
a sense of why we remain a bit skeptical
what the alternatives are and what we
need to do to sort it all out in the
next lesson I'm going to tell you about
searches for dark matter
so what is dark matter
full disclosure we don't know all the
details but it is generally imagined to
be a form of matter that doesn't
experience electromagnetism nor the
strong or weak nuclear forces
so the best are our knowledge it only
experiences gravity
we don't know the form that dark matter
takes but the most common mental image
is it is like a gas that permeates the
Universe floating in the same space that
holds stars and galaxies
think of it as a series of invisible
clouds or a ghost or something that
enshrouds galaxies and clusters of
galaxies just countless subatomic
particles with each particle having the
mass of probably a few or a hundred or a
thousand protons
the honest reality is that we don't know
what individual Dark Matter particles
look like
we are pretty sure that whatever dark
matter is there's a whole ton of it out
there
more or less we think that there is
about five times more Dark Matter than
there is the matter of atoms five times
that's a bold statement given that we
are pretty clueless as to the details of
what Dark Matter actually is how is it
that scientists can be so sure
observations that led researchers to
hypothesize Dark Matter aren't new
nearly a century ago the first relevant
observations arose
in 1927 Dutch astronomer Jan ort was
studying our own Milky Way
as a reminder the modern idea of
galaxies was new at the time it was only
in 1925 that Edwin Hubble submitted his
paper that showed that what was called
at the time the spiral nebula and
Andromeda was actually a spiral galaxy
entirely outside our own Milky Way
Beyond or wanted to learn about our own
galaxies so we studied nearby stars to
determine their velocities
Bert was the first person to demonstrate
that the Milky Way was rotating already
that's a pretty cool thing when you
think about it I mean just the fact that
he figured out that the Galaxy was
rotating even though he was embedded
inside it is pretty amazing
we also encountered him in lesson 13
where it was revealed that he also
figured out that our galaxy was a spiral
but the thing that matters most here is
that he combines his measurement of the
Stars he looked at and the rate at which
they were moving and figured out that it
didn't make sense the Stars seemed to be
moving faster than the laws of physics
allowed
seeing how this works is pretty easy by
and large stars orbit inside a Galaxy
and more or less circular paths they're
really ellipses but they're often
circular enough
in order for an object to move in a
circular path requires a force you may
have put a ball or something on a string
and twirled it around over your head the
string you held in your hand constantly
pulls the ball toward the center the
faster you twirl the object the greater
the tension in the string
of course with stars and galaxies there
is no string instead gravity is the
force that pulls the Stars towards the
center of the Galaxy
but the lessons of the string still
apply the faster the star moves the
stronger gravity has to be
what art did was realize that the stars
of the Milky Way were moving too fast
for The observed gravity to keep them in
check
the Milky Way should have ripped itself
apart
in order for everything he measured to
make sense it would require that the
Milky Way contained twice the mass he
could account for in his measurements
of course this was in 1932 and measuring
the mass and movement of a Galaxy while
sitting inside that same galaxy is a
pretty tricky business
it could have well been that he simply
just didn't make an accurate measurement
nobody was all that worried about where
it's discrepancy but it was among the
first observations that suggested that
something funny was going on
the plot thickened the following year
Fritz zwicki was a Swiss astronomer
working at California Institute of
Technology
he was studying the coma cluster of
galaxies the coma Galaxy cluster is
located about 300 million light years
away from Earth and the constellation
coma veronesis within a few degrees of
the galactic North Pole it consists of
over a thousand galaxies bound together
by gravity
so we can kind of did the same thing for
the chroma cluster is or it did for his
study except for Galaxies instead of
stars
he calculated the mass held in all of
the observed galaxies and then
determined their velocities he then
compared the amount of motion energy of
the galaxies to the gravitational energy
holding them together and he found that
there was a huge discrepancy the
galaxies seemed to be moving far faster
than the force of gravity allowed the
cluster should have pulled itself apart
and yet the Clusters seem to be
thoroughly intact there had to be some
sort of unknown and unseen mass in the
coma cluster according to zwiki's
calculations the invisible Mass had to
be about 400 times greater than he could
see 400 times
Wiki indeed nobody of the era knew what
was going on whether they were just not
seeing galaxies or if there were hidden
clouds of gas or whatever but he had a
name for it zwiki called this invisible
matter Dunkel matiri or dark matter
perhaps I should add a side note to this
discussion which is that while zwiki
estimated that his Dark Matter was 400
times larger than an ordinary matter
more recent estimates are smaller we now
think that about 90 percent of the mass
in the coma cluster is dark matter and
10 is ordinary matter it's still a huge
difference but I didn't want to leave
you with that 400 times number in your
head
so those were the two earliest
observations of data that led
astronomers to think about dark matter
but actually the trail ran cold after
the 1930s
people were aware of the discrepancies
but not much happened until the 1970s
that was when an American astronomer by
the name of Vera Rubin came onto the
scene
Reuben encountered much of the sexism of
the middle half of the 20th century
not all universities would admit women
for their doctoral programs and in the
1960s she and her husband had small
children which made it difficult to
pursue research in the most competitive
fields of the day
instead she decided to study what was
considered to be a safe and
non-contentious topic she decided to
study how fast galaxies rotate
she started with the Andromeda galaxy
after all it is close and very large in
the sky
well Andromeda is dim and hard to see in
detail only using the naked eye it's
much larger than the full moon
okay so it's probably worth getting
slightly more technical for this
and our discussion about ort's work in
the early 1930s I told you that stars
orbit galaxies in roughly circular
orbits and the force that held them in
their circular paths is due to gravity
that's true
it gets a bit trickier when one thinks
about the orbital velocity of stars at
different distances from the galactic
center
it turns out that as the orbit of the
Stars gets larger different fractions of
the mass of the Galaxy have to be taken
into account as governing the motion of
the stars in the center of the Galaxy
only the innermost Stars matter
that kind of makes sense since at the
center of the Galaxy A Star is
surrounded in all directions by other
stars and their effects on the motion of
the star all cancels out
for Star orbiting in the very outermost
outskirts of the Galaxy the mass of the
entire galaxy matters perhaps that's
obvious
and of course in between varying amounts
of the total mass of the Galaxy matter
it's fairly easy to take that into
account and work out the expected
orbital velocity of a star as a function
of its distance from the center of the
Galaxy
I'll put a reference to an example
calculation in the suggested reading
it's actually not too hard it's one of
the few Cutting Edge modern physics
calculations that you can do with a
single semester of physics education you
don't even need calculus
but we don't need to reproduce that here
basically a star near the center of the
Galaxy sees little of the Galaxy's Mass
a star near the periphery sees all of
the mass and ones in the middle see a
range of fractions
that means that the gravity each of them
experiences varies as well
when you take it all into account it's
pretty easy to show that I star orbiting
near the center of a Galaxy will move
very slowly
as you look at stars at greater
distances from the center the Stars will
have to orbit more quickly because of
the increased gravity
the orbital velocity of stars hits a
maximum near the edge of the Galaxy and
those straggler stars outside the Galaxy
will orbit slower and slower as the
gravity decreases that's how it works
slow near the center and outside the
edge of the Galaxy and fastest inside
the Galaxy near the edge
so that's what Reuben was investigating
she would measure the velocity of stars
as a function of their distance from the
center of their parent Galaxy and
compare the measurement to the
prediction based on how the mass of the
Galaxy was distributed what did she see
well near the center of the galaxy
everything was fine prediction and
observation were in good agreement
things worked pretty well inside the
Galaxy until Reuben got to the edge the
agreement there was okay but for larger
radii the prediction was that the
orbital velocity of stars would drop
but that's not what she saw at large
radii the velocity of stars seemed to
remain more or less the same speed as
they were at the edge of the Galaxy
there are a couple of possible
explanations for this but one of them is
that this implies that every Galaxy is
surrounded by a cloud of invisible
matter
zwiki's Dark Matter seemed to be a thing
and Reuben didn't just look at one
Galaxy she looked at many and the story
repeated again and again and again the
stars and the periphery of essentially
all galaxies move faster than the laws
of gravity aloud
Reuben's work by the way is some of the
clearest and simplest evidence for the
existence of dark matter
she was recognized for it in many ways
like receiving a national medal of
Science and many honorary doctorates
also the laboratory housing the large
synoptic survey telescope was renamed in
early 2020 the NSF virus C Reuben
Observatory
the lsst is scheduled to begin
operations in 2022 and when it does it
will be one of the more productive
astronomical facilities on the planet
but for all her Awards she never
received a Nobel Prize in physics which
I personally think is a tragedy her work
really deserved it but with her death in
2016 it's now too late
oh well it is what it is let's get back
to the science
the work of art zwicki and Ruben all
showed that astronomical bodies were
moving too fast to explain using the
known laws of physics and The observed
matter but they are all similar sorts of
measurements telling a similar story
but they're not the only observations
that suggest that dark matter is real
there are other interesting tidbits you
should know about
to understand this different sort of
information we need to revisit lesson 15
which is where we were introduced to
Arthur Eddington the scientist who
looked at the Sun during a solar eclipse
to show that light from distant Stars
can be deflected by gravitational fields
the phenomenon Eddington first observed
is called gravitational lensing
when light from a distant body passes by
a massive body of intermediate distance
the path of the light is bent by gravity
the most dramatic example of
gravitational lensing is when two
galaxies are on an exact line of sight
from Earth with one of them much more
distant than the other
some of the light from the more distant
Galaxy heads straight to the Earth and
is absorbed by the intervening Galaxy
however light doesn't just travel in
that direction light from astronomical
bodies travels in all directions
some of that light passes by the closer
Galaxy and is bent towards the Earth
in the lucky situation of exact
alignment between two galaxies what we
see here on Earth is the nearby Galaxy
looking like you'd expect with a ring
surrounding it that ring which is called
an Einstein ring by the way is a
distorted image of the more distant
Galaxy
the first complete ring was observed in
1998.
if the alignment isn't exactly perfect
observers might not see a perfect ring
but an arc
astronomers have seen a fair number of
these incomplete Einstein rings
my favorite one is called by the rather
boring name
sd-s-ssj1038 plus 4849
but it is informally known as the
smiling face gravitational lens
two adjacent massive galaxies lends a
more distant one the two galaxies look
like eyes and the distorted more distant
Galaxy makes the smile
it's kind of cute
the same phenomena can be seen on huge
distance scales not with individual
galaxies but rather clusters of galaxies
a nearby cluster of galaxies distorts
the shape of even more distant galaxies
the visual signature isn't as obvious as
an Einstein ring nor as fun as the
smiling face one but the arcs of
distorted distant galaxies are obvious
enough and of course the amount of
distortion depends very heavily on the
mass of the nearby cluster of galaxies
if we apply this observation while
thinking about the matter budget of the
universe the obvious question is to ask
how much mass is required to cause the
observed amount of distortion
the second question is if we use
telescopes to add up all of the mass in
the nearby cluster does it agree with
the story The Distortion is telling us
and frequently the answer is no
in fact astronomers can use the redshift
Distortion we talked about in lesson 17
to figure out that the universe is
expanding to figure out how far away
both the nearby and more distant Galaxy
clusters are and we can use that to work
out a map of the mass of the universe
it's all way cool
but and this is the key Point here what
we find is that using this gravitational
lensing Technique we see that there is
more mass in the universe than we can
see using our telescopes that's a big
deal and it makes us think
is dark matter real
the answer is probably but we're not
ready to say that definitively yet
let's review Where We Are
to do that I like to invoke a lovely
metaphor that I believe was first
imagined by a physics Professor
currently at Case Western Reserve
University by the name of Stacy McGaw
he was trying to develop a mental image
that would help us understand what we
know and what we think
let's start with what we know we know
that ort and zwicki and Reuben found
that astronomical objects move faster
than the currently known laws of gravity
can explain given the observed amount of
matter
we know that gravitational lensing
surveys also show more lensing than the
known laws of physics gravity and The
observed matter can explain
there are other observations that I
haven't introduced here but they all
tell a similar story with a disconnect
between what we think we know and what
we observe
think of these observations as roots of
a tree of mystery dark matter is one
possible explanation but maybe that's a
bit hasty what do we know
well if we employ this tree as a
metaphor these roots lead to a trunk
that eventually branches
one branch says that there is something
about physics that we don't know the
other Branch says that there is mass
that we can't see
if we go up the physics Branch it
branches again with one smaller Branch
saying that we don't understand how
things move basically we don't
understand how forces and acceleration
fit together
the other small Branch says that maybe
we don't understand how gravity Works
maybe general relativity is an
incomplete theory that doesn't work on
Cosmic scales
on the mass Branch there are options
there too either there is more mass of
the Cayenne made of atoms say dead stars
extra gas or even black holes or there
is some other mass of exotic and unknown
type that is never been observed
the magaz tree you can move upward from
the branches to the bows to twigs and
finally the leaves which are all of the
possible explanations from a particular
new theory of gravity is one leaf to the
existence of never before discovered
heavy cousins of neutrinos as another
now I can't possibly do this analogy
Justice in just one or two lessons on
Dark Matter it would take an entire
course to do that
the best I can do is use this lesson and
the next to kind of talk through bits
and pieces and wave my hands a little I
think that you'll get the most important
points across
the most obvious possible answer is that
there's just more ordinary matter out
there that hasn't been detected
however were there large clouds of gas
we'd see it somehow whether it be
because it glowed or because it emitted
energy in neither radio age or infrared
or some other non-visible light we've
looked and that isn't the answer or more
accurately we've already taken those
clouds into account
another possibility is that there are
compact astronomical objects like black
holes or brown dwarfs or other things
like that astronomers have looked for
those as well
the method is to look at more distant
stars and to see the compact objects
pass in front of them
you'd expect that such a Transit would
make the distance star dim much like we
talked about in lesson 14 in our
discussion of finding exoplanets but the
reality is counter-intuitive
in fact we'd expect to see the distant
Stars brighten because of the formation
of something similar to an Einstein ring
and astronomers in the early 1990s did
the experiment and did indeed see stars
Brighton in the expected way
but they could use that data to rule out
that there were enough compact unseen
objects floating around to account for
the missing Mass well that wasn't it
researchers also considered more exotic
ideas like subatomic particles called
neutrinos
we encountered neutrinos in lesson nine
and loss of neutrinos should have been
made in the Big Bang
but neutrinos have very low mass and
therefore they move very fast
if those were the source of the missing
Mass they're very high speed would
affect how galaxies grow and assemble
over billions of years
if that were the answer the universe
would look very different from what we
see
for this reason we can rule out Cosmic
neutrinos as dark matter
in fact over the past several decades
astronomers have been able to consider
and rule out all known forms of matter
as being dark matter
if Dark Matter exists it's something new
that we've never encountered before
on the other hand maybe astronomers are
barking up the wrong tree maybe what's
wrong is our understanding of the rules
that govern the emotion of objects and
their theory of gravity
what's up with that
on these ideas the data that validates
or rules out these ideas a bit weaker
but there are some pretty compelling
reasons to think that these ideas aren't
right
we'll get to those in a few minutes but
let me kind of sketch out what sorts of
modifications to the rules of gravity
have been considered
the most well-known proposed change to
the laws of physics was made in 1981 by
Israeli physicists mortar High Milgram
he was looking at Vera rubin's
measurements of the rotation
characteristics of galaxies and accepted
the the data very clearly indicated that
stars in the outermost regions of
galaxies were moving too fast for
ordinary gravity to hold them in
circular orbits
now the relevant equation invented by
Newton is his second law of motion which
says that the force on an object is
equal to its mass times its acceleration
if you ever took physics you'll remember
this law is f equals m a
this equation has been tested to death
in introductory physics Labs everywhere
and of course by professionals
Milgram asked himself how he could
modify that equation so it still worked
in the familiar way but would also
explain the galactic rotation
discrepancies
what he did was say that for large
accelerations and forces Newton was
right but the for very small forces
Newton's second law was wrong
Milgram proposed that for very small
forces the correct form of Newton's
equation was f equals m a squared
divided by a factor to make the units
come out right
Milgram therefore proposed a new version
of Newton's Second Law which worked both
for high forces and very low forces
his theory ignored medium forces which
of course is a problem but he was trying
to address the big questions so it's
okay if he didn't get every detail right
the big idea is what matters and of
course later scientists can work out the
details milgram's theory is called
modified Newtonian Dynamics Ormond for
short
so here's the bottom line milgram's idea
does a great job of predicting the
rotational characteristics of galaxies
this is a big deal but don't get excited
just yet there's more to the story
first the good news
milgram's ability to explain why
galaxies rotate is Reuben observed is a
big deal
it was considered to be a competitor to
the idea of Dark Matter especially back
in the 1980s which was before the ideas
of gas clouds or unobserved black holes
were ruled out as the explanation
however there were problems aside from
not saying anything about how to modify
Newton's second law for intermediate
accelerations
milgram's theory was totally
incompatible with Einstein's theory of
relativity it just didn't work
this was clearly a concern but it wasn't
an insurmountable problem
in 2004 a relativistic version of Monde
was proposed by Jacob beckenstein in a
new theory that he termed teves
which was his acronym for tensor Vector
scalar gravity
beckenstein was educated at Princeton
and he was a professor at Hebrew
University of Jerusalem
beckenstein's theory is pretty
complicated but it modified Newton's law
of motion in ways that were consistent
with Mond and Einstein's relativity
more recently other scientists have
offered other attempts to generate
competitors to beckenstein's Theory
many of these new versions of mon remain
theoretically viable
so that's kind of state of the art on
proposed changes to Newton's law of
motion modifying general relativity is a
more complicated business there are tons
of different ideas out there
theoretical physicists are clever Lads
and lasses each of them could modify
Einstein's theory of gravity in
different ways
you think at this point I'd start
ticking through them one at a time to
tell you whether they're still viable
theories whether they've been falsified
but that would be a complicated
undertaking first there are a lot of
them and second not all of their
predictions have been tested
instead I want to take a step back and
talk about some of the more Universal
tests which apply more generally
okay where are we we have a couple of
competing ideas to explain the Dark
Matter conundrum one is that there
exists some unknown sort of matter that
interacts only gravitationally
the second is that the laws of motion or
gravity should be modified
is there a test that would help us pick
between them
I think the answer is yes although you
should realize that we're diving into
the realm of opinion here
but let me tell you why I think the Dark
Matter ideas the stronger of the two
surprisingly one of the best reasons to
believe in dark matter is the
observations of galaxies for which there
is absolutely no evidence that dark
matter exists
in most galaxies the outermost stars
orbit too quickly to be explained by The
observed matter and known loss of
physics however in the late 2010s
astronomers found the class of galaxies
that rotate exactly as Newton would have
predicted without a shred of evidence
that they contain any dark matter
these galaxies are very strong evidence
for the existence of dark matter
you're probably saying now just wait a
minute but let me explain
if the Unexplained rotation
characteristics of most galaxies can be
explained by modified physics then why
isn't the physics modified for these
newly discovered galaxies that just
doesn't make any sense
on the other hand if dark matter is kind
of like a fog that permeates the
Universe denser here and less dense over
there
it's likely that an occasional Galaxy
will be located in a region of space
where there just isn't much dark matter
it will then rotate like Newton's Laws
predict
it's hard to imagine how these galaxies
that look like they don't have dark
matter could exist if the laws of
physics were the explanation for The
Unexplained rotation curves of other
galaxies
it's a huge Act of irony that galaxies
without Dark Matter are some of the best
evidence for the existence of dark
matter
there is another observation that
suggests that the Dark Matter hypothesis
wins out over the modified physics one
and this one is called the bullet
cluster
the bullet cluster is an example where
billions of years ago two large clusters
of galaxies collided with one another
clusters of galaxies are complicated
beasts they include many galaxies but
they also are surrounded by a huge cloud
of hydrogen gas that surrounds the
entire cluster
the amount of mass in the gas clouds is
usually much larger than the mass in the
galaxies themselves
when the two clusters collide with one
another the galaxies pretty much pass by
one another unimpeded however the
hydrogen gas clouds crash into one
another and stop
thus in a collision between two clusters
of galaxies what you expect to see is
the galaxies of the Clusters separated
from one another but with a big cloud of
gas between them heated from the
Collision this is exactly what you see
with the bullet cluster
the question then becomes what
difference do we expect to see if dark
matter is real versus whether the laws
of physics need to be changed
the defining measurement is to look at
galaxies even farther away than the
bullet cluster and see which ones are
distorted due to the gravitational
lensing effects first observed by Arthur
Eddington in which we first encountered
in lesson 15.
if modifications of physics are real
we'd expect to see more distortions
where the gas cloud is
that's because that's where most of the
ordinary masses if dark matter is real
then the Dark Matter would pass through
the gas clouds and we'd expect to see
more distortions where the galaxies are
and this second scenario is what we see
distant galaxies are more distorted by
the galaxies of the bullet cluster and
not the gas cloud in the middle this is
a clear win for the idea of dark matter
so I went through that last bit pretty
fast but if you're interested in more
detail there's a lot more material in
the suggested reading
as I'm recording this I think the
preponderance of evidence strongly
favors the existence of dark matter
to begin with there is all of the data
that I introduced in the beginning of
this lesson to show why scientists
believe that something is going on
whether the explanation is that dark
matter exists or whether it is because
the laws of physics are incomplete
and the recent observations of the
bullet cluster and galaxies which don't
seem to have dark matter strongly favor
the Dark Matter hypothesis
now you might ask yourself what about
other ways to see dark matter could we
detect it on Earth
is there dark matter in our solar system
can we make it in particle accelerators
like we've done with so many other
hypothetical substances
well those are all good questions and I
could make an entire lesson laying out
all of the data and measurements we've
made
however instead what I'm going to do in
the next lesson is to talk about all of
the known searches for dark matter
well we don't know what dark matter is
we know a great deal about what it is
I think you're going to enjoy that Tale